was there a particular location that was
a little more challenging to decide on
how to present it well the toy store was
the toy department the department in a
department store was a huge a huge set
for us in terms of the work that it
required and and it's also the opening
kind of not the opening set of the movie
but one of the big important set because
it's where Torrez meets Carol and and
you want this kind of it's the whole
world to be created in a believable
fashion so it was it took us it was a
while before we found the right location
for that and we went through a lot of
different options we scouted some we're
in Cincinnati and there were some towns
outside of Cincinnati that had closed
down department stores that were built
in the right era and the scent was so
exciting and we went and scouted them
and they were all wrong I mean one of
them we had been to remodeled in the
1960s and another one was too small and
another one they wouldn't let a shoot
there and it wasn't that great anyway so
we were kept going through all these
different options and I was starting to
be a little scary and then we found this
great abandoned high school a turn of
the Sun turn of the 20th century high
school that had this gymnasium that was
beautiful details because we really just
needed walls floor ceiling columns and
we were going to create the rest so this
gymnasium looked good it had a little
running track and we were going to make
a mezzanine up there with toys which I
had seen in in much of the period
research and the building had no heat or
water at the moment or no electricity
and we started to they started to make a
deal with the owner and then it it fell
through it became too expensive he
started asking for more money I don't
even know what happened but suddenly we
had no location and we really had
nothing and then my decorator heather
leffler said I've been shopping at this
fabric store meal end and they have a
it's a multi floor building and I think
maybe one of the floors would be good
for the toy department so we went and
looked it was a big storage floor and it
was filled with junk I mean just covered
but we knew it was the right place right
a and immediately we brought Todd and he
loved it and we surveyed it and started
clearing it out and so that was that was
the beginning of the toy department
you